day 30 to the general election campaign  were in sunny Yorkshire and leads what  an appropriate place to be this is not  actually the venue for the debate this  is the spin room we're in Yorkshire and  this is the Geoffrey Boycott election  isn't it's the Geoffrey Boycott election  because both of the main parties are  paying very straight bat no one's eating  out for a six for the wild hook shot no  one's even going for a four they its  defensive it's kind of sterile everyone  sticking to their buses and their core  supporters it's notable that both sides  were saying essentially well look at us  we went on a walkabout so that's what  the conservative said this morning  Labour's say well we went our walk  Bowers with Ed Miliband when he did that  in Newcastle but you can count the  walkabouts with random boaters on the  fingers of one hand from David Cameron  and EDD Miliband this is a chance  tonight to get out there make the case  grab that election but do they want to  take